[Laughter]
good morning we are in Houston Texas
and we are about to go too excited to
see the astronauts the ships hey Houston
hey hey hey Houston sir all right so but
first we're gonna go to a Waffle House
get some breakfast and uh here we go you
guys like taking road trips every time
you come back is it like synonymous now
a Grayson TIFF is coming back home
Road Trip times in Texas sucks because
those couple days off its us on the road
true there's that much of a day off yeah
it's more like are you some more energy
now get up and out even though this big
he looks just like Dallas it doesn't
like Dallas
of Texas aesthetic area visiting Houston
for me is kind of like walking through
memory lanes because Houston was a city
that we frequented a lot we came here a
lot and we're growing up because a lot
of her family's here and we had an uncle
that was a dentist so we came down here
specifically for braces and we had to
get that done like every month so we
came here at least once a month and then
a level week it was a waste of a weekend
that was our weekend car no just coming
down to Houston meeting with family
which in hindsight is great but at the
time when you're a kid you're like why
he has I was talking to my mom about
this yesterday coming in I wasn't sure
when the last time I was in Houston and
I fire remember correctly I think it's
well over ten years so this is a I've
been here in ten years how do you feel
coming back with your wife's weird
you're here what's going on you know I
you said that when you brought me that
quad of the hug yeah it's weird that I'm
here yeah same fans like you're here in
Houston that's weird
oh the same feeling that we had I think
at our wedding - it's like jkp we're
here in France your family's here my
family from Hong Kong is we're like this
group of people don't belong together
furthermore we're all like in Paris out
of all places those it was
yeah it's a cool weird weird cool yeah
how do you like being here well I
haven't been much to really have an
opinion
yeah we just got here you know we drove
like 20 minutes out of the way to go to
downtown so that we could see downtown
as we arrived you were in the other car
and I was told that you're pure asleep
and no one started waking me up I didn't
know that was there like for you Hey
thank you so funny
can't go to Waffle House without order
in a waffle you can't come off the house
with that corner in the pork chop
because that is the best thing they have
on the menu or chop that's also very
good yes anything from the house is very
good and must-have yeah exactly exactly
so you can't lose
[Music]
are you excited
[Music]
[Music]
like one of your dreams is to go into
outer space just to float right this is
one night where we were we spent a
couple hours watching lame outerspace
videos like people eating in outer space
washing their faces playing with water
and stuff and there was just
assassinating and I think we peaked
Isaac's interest in terms of wanting to
learn more about space which is why
we're here
[Music]
oh thank you sir we're about to feel how
it feels to be an astronaut they're
about the CIPA when they said
oh man totally how do you do this
this is weird
[Music]
nice let's go explore the moon guys is
it the word that thing you know you see
how you have scratches this is one of
only eight or my rods in the world
because wrong that's like a tile like a
floor tile this moon rock is 3.8 billion
years old
so is any rough under when you see
something like this you're dead I like a
little kid
[Music]
[Music]
Jill's not that outerspace ish break out
their sleeping bag it's working out here
it's really working so cold it's the
coldest beach experience I've ever had
keep mommy what are we doing our dinner
[Applause]
guess what it's a movie in muy bien all
right look at me I'm on a mall Harry
Potter it up Kristen Gryffindor
so are we gonna go to the pier also
have you ever been to the beach when
it's like super cold like this me
neither
mommy have you like in your sleeping bag
I love it you see nice and warm right
your jacket pulled up especially a
little cold and Ellie oh we're not done
oh yeah cow is really not that cool oh
my gosh yeah but it's cold yeah it's
pretty cool
[Music]
sleeping bag as long she's wearing that
coat she is sleeping bag I love sleeping
bag where's this is a kiss point I had
that I had that kind of toy I think
you're just too you're too mom level now
you Hydra warm now cold cool I have a
scarf and to have a jacket under here
dumb nice and more sounds like a
personal problem it is a personal
problem
my buddy Matt Ritter are you drunk
we started talking then he has like this
thing where as soon as he sees us just
having like one or two beers here
automatically things are alcoholic
genetic baby alcoholics or people that
drink like all the time every day I'm
like we only drink while we're on
vacation or trying to have fun that's
true once in a while but it's funny cuz
he's like
[Laughter]
[Music]
Wow it's as big as you
[Music]
I want you to get these that Vanessa
please I know I should gotten one penny
presses I know who to give this to
I know I know this is I think I'm a
freshman school
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chinese-food twice
Oh their trip to Houston we can during
such poor weather though so we didn't
really get to maximize our stay in
Houston
yeah venture now you can mark off
Houston even they didn't get the
signature why rain why yeah alright so
we're back from Houston
Issac learned what song was it I think
me it Sebastian's theme for Walmart yeah
you learned how to play it so all you
know like the first two lines how's it
go I mess up it's ok you're learning
[Music]
knife
[Music]
good job high five
[Music]
nice hey you're so good you know it's so
awesome because I've been seeing Isaac
just practice and practice and practice
the piano like anything that he's being
taught by either Papa Chan or Casey he's
just really trying to practice it every
day and it's so cute seeing how
dedicated he is every time we come to
Dallas he's always playing on the piano
so now we really got to get to actual
lessons
wow I'm proud of you baby we are in
Plano Texas now
actually we stopped from vlogging a
couple days ago after we came back from
Houston we didn't vlog that much in
Houston it was so like gloomy and like
old and we're just trying to stay warm
just family time so it's like yeah we
don't worry about the camera yes if we
stop vlogging and then we didn't vlog
for New Year's and apparently I don't
know what happened during New Year's but
look at my face way too much he went too
crazy
this never happened to me before like
that like really this is actually better
than it was a couple days ago like a
couple days ago now I was never bumpy
but it looked like I got into a fight
and got a little scrappy yeah but now it
just looks like I don't know like rashes
or something I don't know where are we
now though like yeah now we're in Plano
this is where I grew up from the ages of
10 to 18 so I spent eight years in this
neighborhood and I'm jealous of Casey
and his brother they had such a cool
childhood here like just look around
it's like beautiful I don't know always
so jealous of your like you grew up in
this house with
is in your front your this house this
house right here is the house I grew up
in then I saw videos of the inside and
they had like it looked like the typical
like family that you see in TV shows
like that kind of house like that does I
wanted and then we had like oh we had a
whole hiking trail and creeks and
everything across the street from us
yeah this is uh this is where I grew up
man I think I didn't feel like it was
all that privilege and great when I was
growing up here is normal to me
not having seen the world yet you know
and that coming back it's definitely
like that's this pretty cool and it's
very nostalgic now like the TV shows my
life was moral I related to them yeah
yeah that's so crazy cuz for reals like
people really live like I think though
is it frozen frozen lake yeah that's
crazy
remember a pond was frozen back then
yeah we had breaking it had a pond in
our backyard you know we always freeze
every every winter do you remember
fishing here I dare you to just run from
all the way over here just run forward
and land in the water would you do it if
I gave you if I give you a hundred
dollars would you do that oh yeah you
owe you for a hundred dollars you want
to give your mother a heart attack
oh no it was a million it was a million
I used to go fishing over there oh that
looks really nice right now with the Sun
fishing yeah I think because of us
no that's the best sign is new weight
would you actually eat no because catch
and release yeah but this one time we
caught a turtle on accident we weren't
trying to catch the turtle the turtle
just got stuck to the hook and that's
bad it was really sad we pulled it up
and then we're trying to really
say we're trying to keep the hook out of
his mouth and it was stuck it was stuck
onto his like reptile bones reptile
scales and water yeah we felt really bad
after that I didn't really fish that
much anymore and I don't know what
happened I got yeah we were all feeling
really bad like we were all like 13 14
and we're just like feeling really bad
about the turtle and we had to let it go
we didn't we tried Piru try yanking ever
like do like turtle it's gonna hurt let
it go with the hook we didn't know what
to do yeah take it to the vet Oh
I mean we're kids you're just like at
your parents I know shoulda I know we're
just kids there's like oh man his turtle
is hurting and we're yanking pretty hard
for the turtle it's gonna hurt a little
bit
they're trying yanking really hard like
conscience yeah it is really nice here
take my wife back to my childhood home
he's cool
so cute thing I say he gets a little
glimpse of your childhood but being here
yeah
[Music]
oh I get this big I could do some real
cooking action with this one watching
cable TV all to him that's all I did
your mommy is a very much like a boy
right now I always played like a boy
like I never play with Barbies or
anything I was always the one that with
like the worms and like the Rolly thing
oh you're one of those girls
[Music]
[Laughter]
because if you like to have a little
glimpse into lucky I know you don't know
I know imagine we had this in our
backyard or front yard I guess you
wouldn't see me it would never be used
man we should move here then but then I
be spending a lot of money on new
clothes so look at these pants now
illegally shoes now hey it's okay it's
part of being a kid right right good job
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
scary
[Music]